Robert Hughes in The New Yorker piece on
you in may is equipped from Barbara Rose
that says in September 1970 Bob was
wearing love beads a transparent linen
shirt a yellow wide wale corduroy suit
and a black leather coat with nail heads
on the back that spelled out this is not
a coat she says what did I I was
carrying the coats I was not wearing it
when I came through US Customs that was
when you first captured when I first
came to the United well it was when I
came to the United States to try out for
time and it wasn't my first visit to the
United States but it was the one that
caused all the trouble
why were you coming here for anti
magazine because they'd asked me to come
and try out to see if they liked me and
I liked them they were looking for an
art critic and in some moment of
aberration they they got me it was
purely accidental as all things were
there was a book that I just brought out
called heaven and hell in western art
and it sold about three and a half
copies in the United States and getting
luckily for me one of those copies found
its way to the then managing editor of
times and realtor Greenwald who said
well let's try this feller and through a
rather protracted and business they ran
me to earth in London and our marriage
was cracking up at all things favoured a
retreat to England so I thought I'd go
and see what it was like in the States
of course I thought I was going to stay
for two years
so anyway Barbara met me at the airport
and there I was what she didn't mention
was that I'd come from Italy and I had
all these bags of a suitable mixture
called purple hee
which I got from the family and to Santa
Maria Novella in in Florence and I was
going to give him the friends as
presents and the guy going was going
through my bags and he saw these plastic
bags full of this verbal mixture sitting
on top and he said I mean his eyes and
this happened he thought I've got
another one of the stuff and I said it's
poco fee and he said but I said poop
okay how do you spell it
po2 and so I nearly didn't make it into
the United States 27 years later this
has been in bookstores for a couple of
months
what is it this it's a book it's called
American visions which my editor
subtitled the epic history of art in
America it is a book vastly expanded
from a television series that I did for
PBS and for the BBC and it is basically
I suppose a kind of rather opinionated
social history of the American art and
then there's this which is a special of
Time magazine yeah the truck so that is
it's not a condensation of the book that
had to be written again from scratch I
read the whole issue something that I've
never tried before but it's amazing what
the prospect of hanging can do the
television series is over or at least
it's run on the IO television picture
and you the books been in the bookstores
for a couple months the magazine is out
how do you feel intensely relieved and
very like going fishing
well it's a ring out you know a project
like this it's do the whole thing took
me four years and I was a month more or
less on the road promoting it and the
the there was no rest of the ungodly and
he and I'm just glad it's over and I'm
glad it came out well there's also a lot
of copy that's been written about you
too during this period yet depression oh
yeah oh sure
well not during the whole period that
would have been unendurable but I went
you know I crashed at the end of the
series the I mean it wasn't a fatal
crash but I woke up one morning and I
thought yikes life is devoid of meaning
and horrible in all respects you know I
mean I don't know whether you've
suffered from this but it's yeah it's a
medical problems as they suddenly grow
horns and a tail turn into something you
know - although I must say my wife
rather filters if she was dealing with a
little creature from alien sometimes but
no I was no kidding it was bad and they
were caused by overwork you know with
all trails of course to go back into
childhood and but anyway then I woke up
and realized well I've got to write this
damn book I've got to write 200
something thousand words of coffee in
the next nine months and so I had to put
this off more or less on
limitary disciplining I get up at 4
o'clock every morning and had my tea I
was too wired up to have coffee which
you know was a nuisance but there it was
and right 12 to 1500 words a day and do
four before miles a day on the treadmill
if possible and just bang it through
because if the series comes out and you
don't have a book there obviously it's
not the best business practice no it was
it was very hard but they feel like we
get depression what's it feel like it
feels terrible you you you know be the
luckily if you just drop one thing to
concentrate on you can concentrate on
there directly so if I hadn't had the
book to write I would have been in big
trouble
the you feel as though your life is
essentially without meaning you know the
stuff that you've done is not going to
last and that the how can I put it it
deprives you of pleasure in the company
of others it makes you so much Cystic
and sort of self enclosed without being
successfully introspective and it's an
altogether miserable business so what I
did was I you know did what I would I
would never have contemplated normally I
would love to see a shrink I mean
finally at the age of 57 oh I went to a
shrink but you see good Catholic boys
don't go to shrinks what they do is they
go to confession and that sort of gets
rid of the the you know one part of it
for that actually sorting anything out
so I went to see a shrink I took drugs I
you know and I got to say it all helped
a lot the shrink was a fellow fisherman
and it feels a little difficult to sort
out whether we were discussing you know
fly-fishing for striped bass or Meyer
and he put problems but we we did in the
end remember this picture taken that
picture was taken about two months ago
where is it it's in my loft
the bear and Spartan and Missy
appearance at the loft is not a matter
of set dressing as a madman are the
bookshelves you see are empty moving all
my books out in order to rebuild them
oft where is the lock on the corner of
Princeton West Broadway and sugan Soho
in New York how long have you lived
there
Oh God since 1970 70 well yeah that's
rad 1971 and I moved to New York in 1970
I stayed in the Chelsea Hotel for a few
months and then somebody said to me
actually Barbara the person that we
referred to earlier said to me you know
if you want cheap large space then there
are these really cheap big warehouses
down in this unnamed part of New York a
lot of artists were living there over in
Gatlin and when I read about this
painting one of the I guess it may not
be new but it was new to me that you
talked about the artist being a closeted
homosexual yes is that well now I think
it's fairly well known I certainly
didn't doubt image in the literature and
why would I mean whether he was a
practicing gay or not I have absolutely
no idea but you know he was a man of
pictorially very refined tastes and he
had a I mean the big in tribuna far from
being the sturly some of the Midwestern
soil he was I mean he was in fact born
and I ever it's true and he lived there
good deal of his life but the big
influences on him we're around 15th
century Flemish put portrait painting
with its very high finish and intense
concentration of craft and if you said
his mother's gonna pet in China and
periodically craft wood could be
prevailed upon us there I am in front of
the house in American Gothic which is
not the real house of American Gothic
it's a fake American Gothic house which
has been built closer to graduates
profit off school but the sometimes he
would be prevailed upon to put on a pair
of blue bib overalls and you know sort
of and stand in close proximity to a
tree so as to look like a farmer but
that was all part of the promotion
the of American region was in the
thirties what does it mean that so many
different companies have used this grant
wood painting for their own age
it means that it's the American Mona
Lisa now the fame of a painting is a
really mysterious thing I mean nobody
really knows whether Mona Lisa got
famous although I have some theories
this one became fantastically famous I
think it cut through its ambiguity the
the I mean first of all it's a very very
memorable image one which strikes deep
into people's ancestral memory or what
they would like their ancestral memory
to be you know very as the stern Puritan
father holding up the pitchfork
defending the virtue of is not very
alluring daughter and the the it is
humorous and at the same time it's hard
to be sure whether he's where the wood
was praising that kind of Midwestern
rectitude or not
so people project on it that comes from
a painting by Gilbert Stuart the
so-called land I got the Lansdowne
portrait to be it's stupid cop to paint
Washington three times from the life
this is derived from the unfinished
picture and of course it's on the
American dollar bill that's the that's
the canonical image of George Washington
what do you think of the Americans
putting this particular painting on the
dollar I think it was a good idea for a
little putting a painting on the dollar
bill that but they're putting a lot of
zillions of engraved images which were
derived from the painting it's not a
reproduction of the painting but it is
you know a version or there it is yes
that's that's Washington and as you can
see it's reversed by the in gray you
know I mean the in in that fund he's
facing to his right and on the dollar
bill he's facing for his left that's
because it's no ingrate what can you
tell us about givers Stuart I can tell
you a lot about Gilbert Stuart delivered
Stuart was a bit first of all he was a
tremendously able and an immensely
fluent portraitist he was a great
believer in the in the you know in
multiplying his images he used to run up
massively refer to his portraits of
Washington now there's Martha Washington
- yeah he would refer to his portraits
of Washington - which there's an immense
term and as he's hundred dollar bills so
and and he painted I think Nathan and
Joe
in the same week if not in the same day
you know from the life I think at that
Berlin Mitte nearly three over three
original runs of Washington which were
done from the life of the great man
present but he then spun off from those
at least 114 versions and that was what
you had to do you know the you couldn't
tie the president up indefinitely with
photo ops or interact with painting ops
and so the the there was a real demand
for effigies of Washington also served
by people like that appealed both for
you know for I mean I think I think it
was Raphael P or no it wasn't breath oh
my god so long after the book I'm
getting confused Charles Wilson Peale
was the father who founded this dynasty
of artists one of his sons was Rubens
Raphael I can't remember
specialized importing portraits of
Washington just like his dad had and
there are hundreds of them all over the
United States and but of course this is
an age before mechanical reproduction
and here we have Copley certainly the
greatest of American portraitist of the
18th century and this is the again it's
our canonical image of Paul Revere the
the the intelligent skeptical determined
American craftsmen as citizen I mean
it's one of the archetypal portraits of
a skilled American you can see there
this actual painting was on the cover of
David Hackett Fisher's book that's Paul
Revere and they pointed out there that
in the what he's got his hand around you
can see the reflection of you can see
the reflection of the window which is
behind the artist and that Burling spot
on the silver teapot that Revere is just
finished baking is a reflection of the
window and of course that's the large
source for the light in the in the
picture yeah
what's so special about this particular
artist Jonathan saying of them Kathleen
there are a lot of things are special
about him but I would say the thing that
is most special is that he was the well
he was the first original American to
really make a rather grand style out of
what was actually rather my knee and
plane and
you know and came out of the New England
liminal tradition he couldn't at first
attain the sort of grace notes of the
18th century English portraiture but
with that extremely craft from lack
approach of his and that plea you know
and there plainness he actually produced
something which I think was more
valuable that he produced something
which was you know sort of completely
sober and fast unflattering all the
moles and water and winds in place you
know and you know he was the first great
American impugn a great American
empiricist which I might add this card
that we're looking at now John Trumbull
was not an in Trumbull yearn to be a
history painter the problem for being a
history painter in the 1820s was that
Americans Den is now one less interested
in their own past them in their own
future there's a very interesting letter
from I think Adams to trample on this so
possibly medicine to tremble on this
subject saying I see no interest in the
public around us in the commemoration of
the events of the revolution and this
was when the negotiation was going on
for the four pictures of which that is
one which now decorate the rotunda of
the Capitol here in Washington already
Americans in other words were
complaining about the selective and
easier of their their citizenry how do
you do all this how do I do it yeah how
do you remember all this how do you you
know I've been over the years in it for
the last five years you know that I mean
my main problem is going to be clearing
the stuff out of my head in order to get
on with a book on gore or whatever but
when we see in your least exciting
moment what are you doing I mean how did
you compile all of this information and
get to be such an expert in all this
time I've been enough critic working in
America for 27 years you never to be
some stuff rubs off but I'm extremely
curious about America you know there I'm
curious about America in the way that
foreigners are I'm not a citizen I'm an
Australian but nevertheless I'm a and
what's called an alien alien resident
you know none of them stay that way
yeah yeah why well wife's American they
can't take that green card away from me
not now the haven't said anything about
continent misspoke you know
he now I'm going to stay that way
because beyond a certain age when I'm 58
the leopard has difficulty changing his
spots I mean I have for instance I'm
interested with politics but the only
country in which I can be politically
active is Australia and it would seem
sort of ridiculous to abandon my
Australian citizenship and my family has
been active there for so long I mean I'm
not coming from somewhere in order to
completely remake myself you know your
family well you know brother it was an
attorney general he was the Attorney
General my brother Tom yeah in during
the Vietnam use the he was he was
Attorney General at the same time
actually the Mitchell and Mario that
Mitchell was the Attorney General here
he met Mitchell he was so you know he
was given a trip over here to find out
more and better ways of dumping on
Vietnam protesters and he was horrified
by Mitchell because 12 is a true
conservative or not you know a an
egregious schemer like Mitchell
anyway the purpose am now I mean I'll
not have been pretty much embroiled in
Australian politics since the 1900s
weird the early 1900s and the you know
no there's a family history there that
I'm kind of you know that I'm proud of
and with doctors to renege on I could go
back to my original question how do you
do I always add where do you work I work
at home in Charlotte I have a house
there with a burn upstairs on the bone
there is my writing room downstairs
there's my wood shop when I run out of
paragraphs I go down and you know
absentmindedly cut a few dovetails then
I go back up again well you know I mean
one of the stations of writing this
bloody thing was that I didn't get the
notion of both outside cockle travel
once during the whole year I didn't
catch a bluefish I got a couple of bass
on fly that was it but the the anyway I
have my art library there
the half of the top floor of the barrel
is books half is racking room I get up
early in the morning and you know I do
what you do I work and the I found it
excellent for concentration it's
wonderful frustrating because you know
short around and unlike other parts of
eastern Long Island has absolutely no
social mouth of any description you know
which is actually quite a good thing you
know I mean all those hotshot agents
with their big cocoa colored Mercedes of
totally any sound are afraid of the
water and so they don't come across very
and it's also you know if you're at some
earthly boring dinner party you can jump
up or my wife can jump up with a
stricken expression on the face and say
my god it's night like it's already nine
o'clock on the last penny leaves of 9:45
I'm terribly sorry Samantha we have to
go you know the look the biggest mission
about work I ever had because when I was
a kid I of course I thought you know
when I was in my 20s I thought it was
done by inspiration they was from Allen
law head now the last dead who took me
under his wing and was said to speak my
surrogate father as a Roger and he did
this thing which I found out early in
comprehension like a United seemed so
strange he would get up at 6:00 in the
morning and at seven o'clock he'd be in
the civil writing room up the you know
up the hill at the back of his place in
Italy and he would stay there until 11
o'clock I mean he wouldn't come out he
would you know he wouldn't take
telephone calls he would do anything
like that and surprise surprise at the
end of the morning you'd usually have
700 minutes someplace is a reference to
having an exceptional memory I have a
very good memory I think it's beginning
to decay a bit under the you know the
influence of age booze and other things
but no I think I'm pretty good memory I
used to be CI when I was a boy when I
was a Jesuit school they would make you
know apologies about had memorized huge
chunks of stuff but I you know had a
some people found dis owners I found it
delightful and then I can still no I'm
not going to do it but you know I can
still quote ad libitum from humorous
Shakespearean tragedy I could I could
recite you the wasteland by heart if you
like but I'm not going to it
we've got better things to put now this
is you know interesting enough in the
magazine version and which this is the
Time magazine special the pictures are
that they it's a lot bigger this is in
the book yes by the way what is this
that is a painting painted in the 1890s
called memories of 1865 by Joe by John
Frederick Peter who was a magic realist
who his paintings actually were quite
popular in America but one of the
interesting things about Peter is that
he has this exceptionally nostalgic kind
of coating you know this is called
memories of sixty-five because that's
the end Lincoln was assassinated and
there's Lincoln's daguerreotype and
there's this old rusty bowie knife which
is one of his studio props which was
picked up on a Civil War battlefield and
it's hanging over in Missouri hanging
over the image of Lincoln like the sword
over Damocles and the deliberation of
the thing is shown by that card there
which reads something of the house which
was a common kind of card used I think
in table settings at the time and it
originally read ahead of the house so
the life is figuratively cutting off the
head and it's an allusion to the
assassination of the president what do
you think of art around Abraham Lincoln
that you seen Peter well you've been
around legal is Lincoln in general I
mean there a lot of it there's a lot of
there's a tremendous amount of
photography Lincoln was the first
president whose image was really really
ramified by photography but that's of
course because there was a popular
demand for his work he was the first
president to the age of photography who
really was regarded as popular and you
know what most demigod like well at
least for northerners and the but
official paintings of Lincoln are for
the most part pretty dull I mean the you
know as American or any other official
report which it tends to be but it's the
you know it's the photographs that that
we remember him by now this is a under
covers and we see all the time they
Merriam flag but it's by Jessica Jones
now when was this gun this was done in
1955 and what asteroid cause then
strangely enough you know why well
because you know the the caused a big
stir in the art world because if people
couldn't be sure whether they were
looking at a flag or at an image of a
flag I mean it clearly was an image of a
flag but if so you know the painting
consistent
nothing but the flag and so it's safe
happen all sorts of odd especially much
safe philosophical ontological
vibrations around so the one thing that
didn't happen was that unlike later
artists who incorporated the flag their
work jobs didn't run into any flack for
defacing the flag or for blasphemy
against who is he
Jones is now I'm a well he's certainly
one of America's leading painters he was
always bracketed with Bob rauschenberg
you know at the in the 50cm he is
sometimes regarded as one of the fathers
of pop art but he's not really you know
because pop out is a very different kind
of Enterprise to Jones but John's was
infatuated with popular culture and he
wanted to find images which as he put it
was so well known that they were not
well seen flags targets stuff like that
and I think you know the early work up
to about 1960 it was a terrible thing to
say that you like an artist really work
better than his life but I do you know
without without disrespect the Americans
treat the flag differently in another
country absolutely they're obsessed with
the flag in Australia or even in France
or in England you don't have those
rituals surrounding it I mean America
you know in America they're specified
ways of folding it at Bristol must not
be allowed to touch the ground
politicians always wish to bring in you
know very irate politicians on the right
many of them would like to see in an
actual amendment to the Constitution
protecting this icon from the Faceman
tour burning or whatever I mean if you
burnt an Australian flag you know nobody
would give a damn which I guess is why
people don't burn them the impacted the
flag to Americans is a curious kind of
almost living presence it has the sort
of Eucharistic aspect which it generally
lacks in other countries I mean I dare
say that if you pulled out a tree cone
or you know and started ostentatiously
trampling on it in front of the shop
that they did they did coûte in Paris
some cockeyed come up and give you a
whack with these better until you to
move along but they don't have
constitutional amendments about it I
think as for the Union jail but then
there's that double side because one
wants to preserve they were Americans
like to preserve the flag against
blasphemy or defacement but at the same
time they make it
adamant food from from girl's Underpants
to advertising signs at gas stations I
mean nobody thinks there's anything
weird which I do rather about a gas
station social rounding itself with
hundreds of old glories just for the
purpose of advertising and it sort of
seemed abandoned I have a next-door
neighbor out in Shelter Island well Mike
right next door who has this flagpole in
the back of his house and night old
Laurie goes up and he has a spotlight on
it and it sort of irritating action you
wonder why he's making such a flat
noodle over it is it to say I'm American
I live in America but we know he's
American we know religion America it's a
nutty he's a retired cop anyway let me
I've got a bunch of reviews here that
you know the television shows Monson
past if I waited available Jing Bao
should we get it on cash yet absolutely
please do what's it cost you uh I don't
know do not concern myself is these
mundane preoccupations I think actually
they have a price could give Paul
Richard in then why should post wrote
this about the television thank you and
I want you to when did you first think
about done television about doing
television I don't have 1982 after I'd
says after I'd finished chocolatier and
something called American visions
popping around well it wasn't called
American visions then the I was looking
around I thought you know there is a
terrific subject here and it's really
strange a terrific subject for
television and it's really weird that
nobody in America has tried this one and
so I started checking it out and the
more I did the more convinced I became
that there was a player you know really
interesting television series to be made
about American asserted social meanings
as it were and originally I wanted to do
ten programs and there wasn't the money
for that and there wasn't any money for
it initially I mean the BBC shelter
because what they were never going
through a sort of period of the MTV
issues you know the didactic miniseries
was a thing of the past you know here I
was a sort of little Velociraptor
careering around after Kenneth Clark
steer X and
so the stuff was extinct it's rough
extracted liver will be great disrepute
all Richard said in his review he said
Hugh set out to paint an epic a mural of
America as one might view it through its
art through its churches chairs cars
it's a newness and its rectitude its
follies and then justices and its art
world hype but then the medium trapped
him his series of co-production of BBC 2
and Time Warner was created by
committees by teams of TV specialists he
has never got to paint a mural he
envisioned he only got to sketch ah well
that's an interesting criticism because
it's partly true and partly not it is
true that the nature of television
somewhat changes the arguments you can
make you know television is bad for
abstract argument it's good for show and
tell
the it demands a simple narrative very
simple iconically sir and they had
certainly true that the book is richer
than the television series but I think
within terms of what telly can do series
is reasonably successful there are parts
of it that I think are hokey the Dumber
can tell you what they are and I'm sure
there are you know what they are in here
but I am I mean what Richards
essentially is saying here is that the
book is a better account than the
television series of American artists
various ramifications and I would not
disagree with him there it is but at the
same time I think the Tony series has a
certain value and interest ocularly for
people who might have no previous
experience experience of American art
how long did it take you to the
television part it took three years
three years total concentration yeah I
mean I was thinking about it before then
you know and I would send resentful and
intrusive faxes to the BBC saying come
on why don't you will get off the pot
you know but the the actual planning had
work on it was about three years and the
BBC ran it before we saw it here in
America
that's right with Australian television
ran it before the BBC did it went out to
Australia in July last year then in
England in
October and finally here
thank God why would it people that live
in Australia or in Great Britain be more
interested in it than we would be well
it's not that they're more interested in
just that they had first dibs on it the
one thing that I wanted to avoid was
having it go out last year because I've
been in America because I would not have
had the book ready by then and you know
to be brutally candid about it you know
the the the series as with all previous
television series where they were
talking about Sagan's Cosmos or Ken
Burns on the civil war back than 30
years ago with Kenneth Clark the series
has to function as an extended
commercial for the book what did they
say to you in Australia and Great
Britain but I love though and loved the
series in Australia what they say about
America because of it they thought it
was a very fair and reasonable who
balanced portrait of America with a few
jabs and you know and the same in
England they did the the this is the
curious thing I mean the a couple of
rather cranky critics who have said that
this series and book are intended as
kind of a sort upon the image of America
you know written by this we had a
liberal foreign letter nothing could be
further from the truth but the idea of
having a souffle with no ground glass
rulers at all I think would be
intolerable in a conservative
publication called the Weekly Standard a
fella by the name of David I'm not sure
if I haven't read this well gelernt der
GTL er n te ra probably not pronouncing
I apologize to Alta huge you can use and
art critics of American visions I just
want to read you this he says Hughes
tells us that American culture is in
deep trouble and that today's u.s. art
is largely no good
that is not true that is not what I'm
saying I'm saying that a very can
capture is in some trouble and I'm
saying that quite a lot of what is being
promoted as the most promising or
whatever out of the last 10 or 15 years
has been good but I'm not painting an
absolutely negative espically
paradox he also says he's non-american
Estelle's most when he convinces us that
the crisis is grave but has no ideas
about how to fix it
well it with us you know when a car
begins to slow down on the myth curious
noises from the transmission room smoke
starts coming out from underneath the
hood
you don't actually need to be an
engineer to perceive that something is
going wrong with it
I am deeply tired of people with quick
cultural fixes there was a whole
industry as you well know living in
Washington of you know people you know I
mean running all the way from A to B you
know from Bill Bennett to Mariano
setting up a lot somewhat of a bit
costly woman's name is the the there is
this whole industry and in trying to
persuade people that various unspecified
movements in the direction of virtue and
charity and what-have-you are going to
fix what's wrong with America I don't
think that any you know if there is some
single way of fixing what's wrong with
the the art world I am quite unaware of
it I think the truth is that cultures do
go into a sort of slack water sometimes
you know they do go into periods in
which their energies are dissipated and
not felt now I think it's entirely
possible that we might have a few better
artists around if you had better art
training but I don't think that would be
the you know an automatic quick fix it's
very hard today for an artist to
navigate satisfactorily in a cultural
environment which so much of the air in
the room is taken up by mass media this
was not a problem in the 19th century
there were no competing mass media they
will know there was no television there
was no film etc etc people's sense of
reality is so much generated by mass
media today mediated by it that the arts
of painting and sculpture drawing and
what-have-you
seemed distinctly powerless against the
cataract of images that we get from
other media if you're going to tell an
amateur for five places to go in this
country to see the best American art or
art that is America it may not be the
best art well would you sent it I'd send
them how to send them to the Whitney
Museum in New York our Jenna from New
York you know they have a look at
Washington and then the the National
Museum of American Art here which is a
branch of the Smithsonian is probably
the fundamental collection of American
art in this country other strange thing
is
it's not as well-known as it ought to be
I mean you think it was this is a
complete impossibility that you could
have a National Museum of American Art
in the capital of America that was not
all that well known in comparison say to
the National Gallery this is the one
that connected to the National Portrait
Gallery it's the one that's connected to
the National Portrait Gallery and the
the and its collection is really
extraordinarily interesting I mean
there's great stuff at the Corcoran too
you know the here in Washington I would
send them to I mean those two of the
obvious standards of course there's no
place there's no single place which is a
repository of every possible kind of
American architecture you know but you
know where are the places you have to go
to see that all over Chicago I was about
to say Atlanta but not Atlanta obviously
but the South you know Virginia New York
it depends on what you're looking for
the I would certainly send them to
Chicago for the connection of the of the
national music armament of the the Art
Institute and the terror museum which
has some very very good specifically
American paintings if you can have any
American aren't you wanted in your home
what would it be what would it be I'd
like to have a great hopper which is a
great hopper I've got abides having had
a total them there to gratefully early
Sunday morning such an extraordinary
picture certainly magic one who is Ed
hopper it would hop them don't call it
people advocated off it Ward Edward
Hopper was a deeply inhibited
professional unspectacular artist
returned world truth about the
conditions of life in the American you
know sort of spiritual condition of life
in the American city than anybody else
in the 1930s he was an extraordinary
poet educated I mean he was he was
trained by Robert Henry who was the
leader of the ashcan school he studied
in Paris and as one can see from the
pictures he was very deeply formed by by
French illustration of the 1890s and
people like also like Mel a and he was
better at painting the spaces between
people
and just about anybody you know you
always feel as though you're improving
on something with you see these I mean
very aren't Nighthawks you know one of
the canonical American pictures he had a
tremendous effect upon popular culture
camera men love him the house in psycho
is a hopper house the house in giant on
the Prairie of need he left he died in
1967 he was born in 1890 snow 18 1880
something I think I can't remember his
birthdate his other places were Cape Cod
as you can see there you know that that
haunting picture of that blonde standing
and Lee slightly too small doorway that
little cottage and the sea like and I
would like just for another breast early
in the morning wonderful picture and he
no hopper really defined a side of the
American imagination was as no one has
done that that's in part a sort of
almost a joke picture if he shifted a
little bit that way you can see a
portrait of his wife Joanna Manson he
was a real shrew yelling at him out of
you know that this failing gas station
owner who's hopper himself the road is
empty he's being bypassed by history who
else I couldn't lose nagging him who
else would you put in here at home you
could have anything if I could have
anything at all anything American well I
can't say that I'd turned out a great
Pollak I would like to have a I would
like to have one really really good
Winslow Homer watercolor I think he just
used the greatest water colorist
practically since Turner has an
astonishing virtuoso of watercolor and
also the last 32 pictures one which I
dearly love you know everything to do
with the sea and yeah that's an author
legend that is here in Washington that's
in the natural national gallery here who
is went on Winslow Homer was say well
he's a man about whose character not a
hell of a lot is known because he is for
favorite words according to such friends
we had were mind your own business and
they he started off painting rather
drawing Ripple
tires of the Civil War in the oh you
know do that he was there at the front
in the 18c in the early 1860s this
picture here a veteran in a new field is
probably I think the most moving the
least direct of all pictures to do with
the Civil War I mean the man is a
veteran he's come back he's mowing the
wheat but it also alludes to material
war massacres of entry our town and
Gettysburg you know which took place in
wheat fields prisoners from the front
young Union young issuing an officer
surveying these for these three
prisoners you know there's this little
and there's this Hellfire Kentucky and
Virginia on the front you know looking
as mean as hell sort of people to face
back McVeigh there's a an old man who's
too old to change and there's this
cracker kid who's too young to know
anything I mean people say this is an
objective picture of course it's not
it's a piece of wartime propaganda you
mentioned in your book that a lot of
people write about your position on
slavery that that's one of the biggest
problems we've had with slavery itself
was naturally but it's an interesting
fact it doesn't you know I mean
certainly there are 19th century genre
paintings of slaves and there's one very
good one by Eastman Johnson of a scale
of some escaping slaves on a horse it's
a pretty fine picture then the but
enlarged slavery doesn't show much or
show up much in the you know in the
painted record of American I've already
read comments on slavery did the and
when they do they're usually in the form
of you know the sort of Jolly jolly old
water watermelon chewing you know it's
sort of like Kuhn operated it it
presents the same household as a kind of
simple Arcadia or tends to we were
talking about your television show and
your special for time aging and your
book and now the sales of your
television show up it's gonna make a lot
of money for you I hope so I would be a
hypocrite and a fool to d'lai that I
hope it would is it going I don't know
how much Mellie is a lot it's going well
they have a first printing of 100,000
it'll take a while to shift 100,000 at
sixty-five dollars per but I have no
doubt that will be reprinting by
Christmas this is actually if I can say
say without sounding like some sort of
snake oil salesman I think this book
actually does feel some kind it's a
niche you know in America the pressures
because people are really curious about
American art much more so than they were
when I mean Americans are much more soda
my first coffee and you know so much of
the American story is inscribed in
charge and I think you know it may fit
into a kind of general interesting
American self-consciousness
how many of this time magazine special
was printed five million five half a
million for the newsstands and four for
the half million for subscribers and how
many of the videos work I have no idea
actually but that they can sort of do a
little more ad hoc way you know you
don't have to do a whole big edition of
videos and then hope you sell it you
could you know gear at water to learn we
talked early in this discussion about
depression
have you gotten over all that oh yeah we
got you out of it
hard work help what would you recommend
bust of my friends what would you
recommend to someone that you know what
would you avoid don't be ashamed of it
don't think you can bash your way
through it before it's time but just
remember it's great at us which is the
hardest thing we've all to remember and
above all or you know try and try and
get on you know I mean if you've got
some project you know true you if you
see I'm very lucky I am I'm living as
you do doing things that I really like
doing most people don't but if you're
lucky enough to to do that you know use
it how would you avoid it though I mean
you can't you cannot you cut it's like
treading on a water moccasin you don't
know it's there and suddenly Wango you
know and the the if it's very quick and
it's of course it's totally unfamiliar
this is the thing you just have no idea
what's happening to you you know you
in the and it's not as though you wake
up on water when the entire world has
changed but you know in my case had
changed over about a week I kept
thinking out and showed this to the back
of my mind get rid of it but I couldn't
it just kept snowballing and how do you
feel now this project over I feel
immensely relieved hopeful and really
looking forward to a holiday I'm going
to go to Australia back home to Sydney
I have weeks promotion to do on the book
there and then I'm going up to a place
called willpower which is on the Gulf of
Carpentaria on the Arafura sea it's that
big bite out of the top of Australia and
it's just full of big fishing you know
crocodiles that you wouldn't want to
meet and I'm going to take my godson
young Alexander with me and also his
father has never been there and which
will sit around the campfire it boil mud
crabs and sing sad songs about the
perfidy of women it happened that they
how many children do I have one son how
old is he he's nearly 30 what's he do
he's a sculptor and your wife by the way
my present wife Victoria yeah
oh she she's a garden designer she does
I mean she basically you know she's but
they used to call a housewife were you
later she picked me up after a lecture
in 1977 I was doing a lecture on Bob
Rosburg in San Francisco and after a
certain that a preamble of the form and
note left by hotel this beautiful
redhead appeared from out of the
audience and said okay we're going to
dinner and we've been together more or
less ever since it was very very lucky
have you ever painted yes but badly but
enough to know how difficult it is to
make a good picture
I used actually the whole day you know
to have exhibitions and you know sort of
in the sail the sails from them would
sustain my
toddling steps as a young writer but
when I went to live in Italy in 64 the I
realized one day I was living in quarter
kilometers just about the only
completely art free town in all of Italy
had because I don't know head was there
and
the I I realized after one of the you
know I had this little motorcycle and I
used to go everywhere
Honda no but some reference 1000 IU x'd
to when I got to New York I got the 700
750 and then a Harley a7 Norton 750
could initially added think automotive
would see and the it was not a large
caliber back it was about a 400 didn't
gotcha around and the the so I went to
every provincial museum and crypt and
church and God knows what you know in
that circle out you know from northern
Marcio it's just north of Rome and I was
up to Florence from Siena and the over -
over - one beer at the end of two and a
half years of that I although you know
I'd ever studied art history
I'd overcome my initial fears of
presenting the work to somebody - people
who had I realized that I'd seen an
awful lot of stuff you know not in
slides either so I'm very very I'm a
very strong believer in the relation of
works about to their environment it
makes to be a huge difference if say
you're looking at a you know the
terrorist landscape in the back of a
15th century Italian crucifixion so
Piero della Francesca
and the the then you walk outside and
there is that say essentially that same
terrorist lands back in the hills and
the the it gives the thing a location it
gives something a cultural context of
all sorts of you know sort of
ramifications of that Italy talked with
it how much for my education quite a lot
but I have no university degrees the
great things were predicted for me when
I when I went to university but the idea
was you see if I was going to be a
lawyer like everybody like every other
male and in the family and so it was
thought beneficial that I should do an
art law course combination you know ba
followed by law so that I wouldn't be
complete little barbarian and
I just got out of this as a reporting
school in which I had been in your
boiling with infantile testosterone for
something like five years and of course
pop our chicken and you don't think of
anything but girls and pubs and you know
University journalism and I succeeded in
failing first year arts which is a
course that a reasonably intelligent
amoeba
even an Australian amoeba could have
cursed and these so panic and confusion
and what are we going to do with the de
Montford young Robert and so at this
point I rather defiantly said oh I want
to go away to Paris I want to smoke
girls who wear a beret and paint and
look at naked women and hear well like
hell are going to let me do that so now
I think that as a sort of compromised
studying architecture but I never
completed my degree in architecture
using the guy I got within a year of it
but then somebody well actually it was
Alan lion the founder of Penguin Books
it was out in Australia cockpit er he
was interested in Australia national
collector to the business he saw that
there was no book on the subject you
know there was no general book on the
subject and so anyway I he commissioned
me to write one and goddammit that
things still imprinted came out in 1966
what does it feel like and I've got all
these reviews here just the headline
here with Robert Boynton in The New
Yorker the lives of Robert Hughes he's
the world's most famous art critic the
potential of bus laughs Havel of down
under a little and a man ready to trace
his own gunpowder trails and then you've
got Peter platens who wrote in Newsweek
now that's your competitor yes of
Newsweek said reigns over American art
criticism and you know I could sit here
and read all these other reviews that
almost all of these are other
exaggerated incomes look I have to tell
you I've been I'm deeply grateful both
to blunt an end to Peter and and to
others for saying these complimentary
things but it has to be pointed out the
being I mean being the world's most
famous art critic if that's what I am is
rather like being the world's most
famous beekeeper I mean it doesn't
guarantee a hell of a lot
and it is largely because I write for
time of course I mean you know the the
Peter plugins writes for Newsweek and
you have an automatic built-in
circulation there but the the listen I'd
be a hypocrite if I said I didn't enjoy
that kind of stuff but has to take into
the green over with a grain of salt
I mean if you go around you know
something on the doors of restaurants
that are hard to get into and saying I
want a table for six right now and the
world's most famous are critically
becomes some intolerable beast in the
review he says that you're an
english-speaking Alexis de Tocqueville
oh my god well that's again that's very
nice of Himalayas you know and I I mean
what am I supposed to say yes I am an
english-speaking Alexis de Tocqueville
or no I am NOT an English I mean I'm
it's tremendously flattering that there
should be anybody intelligent out there
who would think so but I do not believe
that this book has the same fundamental
value as photography olds travels in
America
I hope there's some value there whether
that is a work by Edie Kienholz called
the portable War Memorial kina Holmes
now last dead was a tremendously strong
vernacular political artistry the the
you know took all of the dark side of
American life as his field and it's a
yes it's an anti-war satire and you know
on the left you can see the the version
of the Marines raising the flag at Iwo
Jima with a Uncle Sam Montgomery Flags
Uncle Sam behind them but you know on
the blackboard which you can't read in
this reproduction there are the names of
something like 300 countries which it
ceased to exist because of war during
the last hundred years there are three
three hundred states and then you know
there's the your average Joe American
couple you know the Pentagon business
going on as usual having a having a hot
dog with this killer of a real dog
beside them and you know what it's about
is war as business as usual where is
this that is really horrific it is
called the
I think it's called the state
institution or something like that
Kienholz worked for a while as an
attendant in a Californian madhouse and
he was horrified by the way that the
patients were treated when talking about
1960 now and so here are these two
dreadful emaciated figures whose heads
you can't see this in the rep row have
been replaced by go fishbone in which
these live fish is swimming erratically
they're on a double cot as you can see
and one is dreaming the misery of the
other you know there's no escape from
this circle there's this neon court
balloon around the figure omelette in
the top bunk
it's a picture of an eternal neck I mean
it's a image of an eternal nightmare and
it's constructed of course it's not a
painting you know the father you get in
your book the more unusual the art is
well yes later the further you get into
American history the more unusual the
art becomes what's what's caused that
modernism and the the you know just more
you know an opening up of different
modes of technique and and above all I
would say you know the the entry of a of
a more experimental and critical frame
of mind among American artists I mean
really the you know the the the the idea
that art should have functions other
than official ones really only came to
America at about the same time as we do
to the rest of the world they just say
you know sort of after the 20th century
began where ever happened to art like
this or whatever but people still love
it Norman Rockwell yeah absolutely the
Christmas turkey I mean though your
Thanksgiving turkey what am I saying I
put that in there for obvious reasons
you know the rockball had an enormous
effect upon the American imagination he
had this great consoling you know
binding kind of effect nobody knows what
his paintings look like in the sense
that nobody has ever seen practically
speaking the Norman Rockwell and the
original they were all designed for
reproduction but he was one of the most
powerful disseminators of a certain kind
of American dream his imagination was
quite authentic
that there's ever been in this country I
take him I mean I don't you know I don't
think he's Rembrandt it's Jackson
Pollock but I you know the the tendency
to write off Rockwell I think is the
cubix you're looking at him
Rican society through the turf which is
what this book tries to do you know you
can't rattle off more than one occasion
we found this oh that's a thing in a lot
of books that people have written
including a book written about Eleanor
Roosevelt used to go out there and sit
and look at this yeah that is that is
st. Gordon's of statue it is
commemorative figure which has no name
no title
it was a funerary Commission in which
Adams commemorated his wife clover who
committed suicide Henry Adams in
reiatives and he got Saint Gordon she
was by a country mile the best American
sculptor of the 19th century to do it
and I think there have been two
unquestionably great oval I mean there
have been a lot of very good ones but
two unquestionably great American
sculptors and ones in the 19th century
and that st. Gordon's on the other one
was in the 20th century and that's David
Smith and some Gordon's residual was a
tremendously interesting figure by the
way what's next well I got to
automatically print to write a book on
Goya if that sounds a bit unenthusiastic
it's not meant to be it's just it's
going to take me a long time to do it so
I think what I'm going to done I'm not
going to do any more television for a
while I've been asked to do a series
about Australia for the year 2000 I
don't think I'm going to do it it's too
bloody disruptive you have no home life
left have no private life left and I
don't know I think perhaps as a result
of the depression the shrinkage the
treatment of all the rest of it and a
lot of introspection to bring on I might
actually delve back a bit I think I
might write a memoir about growing up
Catholic in Australia they accept that
you know it would be quite unlike most
men was a childhood that written these
days and that nothing nasty will happen
in the woodshed there will be no
predatory uncle groping me behind the
the sacristy none of that happened I was
a fairly happy kid if you were an
American and could vote in this country
which way would you go
the reason I asked that by the way
because you're characterized in a lot of
these reviews is hitting the right and
the left that's right well to tell you
the truth I don't you know I
I should rather feel a plague on both
you parties at the moment well if see I
have a intense dislike of Clinton his
image manipulation his hypocrisy is you
know the you know and that awful sort of
brand of studio therapeutics that he's
always dragging out and waving in the
air like a dishrag but on the other hand
you know the I mean I'd vote for the
party of Abe Lincoln but I would not
vote for the party of Newt Gingrich or
Dick Armey
or any of these guys so in a way I mean
I guess probably I would tip towards the
Democrats but the the but only only with
reluctance what do you think the future
American art is based on that I don't
know but I hope I'm around to see it
the see this you know I'm not a absolute
decline it started the the you know and
I think I think they're going through a
bit of a rough patch up to be notice
slack water so to speak at the moment
and there are any strong cultural tides
running you know at least in the name of
the visual arts I mean one thing is for
sure
it's going to you know people are going
to keep on making out in America they're
going to keep on making images that
explain themselves to the do to one
another and to themselves they you know
there is always going to be that desire
in America because it simply it just
seems to be implanted in you know human
kind but what form it will take
I really don't know why did you pick
this for the cover because it tells you
a bit of a story it tells you to the
themes of the one of the major themes of
the book which is Nancy you know the
affected landscape upon American
imagination you know this heroic idea of
landscape there it is this great valley
out in Albuquerque with lightning
striking at the poles that have been put
up by the artist remoter de Maria so
it's both old and new yeah there it is
the it seemed better than running a you
know a detail of a 19th century
landscape it tells that part of the
story very concisely and also I think
the rather marvelous work about that
thing of de Maria's and its dramatic
entrance cancer
stands out building schools and our time
is up and here's the cover of the book
it's called American visions the epic
history of art in America and our guest
has been Robert Hughes thank you very
much